during the height of the pandemic many
nevadans turned to unemployment for help
just to get food on the table Dieter or
the Department of Employment training
and Rehabilitation is the office
responsible for verifying and handling
those claims new tonight eight news now
investigator David Charn shows us how
they made some pricey mistakes
overall how much money do you owe Dieter
almost thirty thousand dollars thirty
thousand dollars Philip Daniel isn't
getting from Dieter but money they want
him to pay them when I applied they gave
me the money so I assumed okay
everything's good Daniel applied for
both state and federal benefits amid the
coronavirus shutdown in 2020. what did
you have to prove to them I gave them a
tax return He says within weeks he was
receiving a few hundred dollars to get
by living expenses rent food but it's
not like you were out buying a car no
absolutely not but then the email
started at that point I thought it was
either a glitch in the system or a scam
it wasn't a scam but a demand Daniel is
one of tens of thousands of nevadans who
now owe money back that's a lot of money
to overpay somebody how does that even
happen there was a lot of weeks that
were paid out that adds up quickly Chris
Sewell is dieter's new director brought
in under Governor Joe Lombardo we're in
a lot better shape than and we were a
few years ago I think everyone
understands that are we out of it no
Dieter is facing a six-month backlog for
current unemployment claims as employees
work to get people money a whole other
team is Fielding calls from people like
Daniel trying to keep the money they
have the 8 news now investigators
learning the department sent out more
than 84 000 Pua overpayment notices Pua
or Pua pandemic unemployment assistance
was a federal program enabling states to
give benefits to the self-employed or
gig workers how does someone get
overpaid for unemployment I entered
something wrong
they didn't enter their correct wages
correctly or something along those lines
something very simple those owing the
state money can appeal for those people
I'm glad we got on the money but if
there was a mistake made we also need to
correct that but some overpayments are
fraud Dieter estimating it gave out more
than 640 million dollars in fraudulent
payments from both state and federal
coffers well it's not acceptable I'm
embarrassed do you understand the
frustration from people who feel like
they weren't listened to for so many
months and then they finally get a
paycheck and it's wrong I understand the
frustration of one that I understand the
frustration of not being paid timely and
it's not acceptable
we're going to correct it Daniel says he
finally got through to Dieter but his
appeals were all denied he'll pay back
the money month by month but never got
an answer as to why their mistake is
costing him do you think they should
have looked at all that stuff before
they paid you obviously
Dieter has recovered more than a hundred
million dollars in fraud including some
overpayments we asked how much they
think they overpaid those tens of
thousands of people and they did not
have an estimate for us I'm David charns
8 News Now